What you'll find when you start to poke around, either at the code or
at the documentation, is that a large value of
C means that you're going to get more training points correct.
So what that means in practice is that you get the more intricate
decision boundaries with the larger values of C where it
can wiggle around individual data points to try to get everything correct.
But at the cost of something that,
that could be a little bit more complex than you liked it.
Figuring out exactly how much you want a straight decision.
Figuring out how much you want to have a smooth decision boundary versus one
that gets things correct is of course part of the artistry of machine learning.